Lego video games have seen a Resurgence
recently after years of being associated
most closely with successful but often
very similar Platformers from TT games
the last few years have given us the
minimalist Legos a builder's Journey the
clever physics Puzzler Lego bricktails
and the ambitious Lego Star Wars the
Skywalker Saga it's in that environment
that we're getting Lego 2K drive a
striking combination of influences as
diverse as Mario Kart and Burnout
Paradise that uses the Lego license to
add both humor and smart gameplay
applications best of all it's an
absolute blast to play the structure of
Lego 2K Drive unfolds in layers that
help to illustrate just how multifaceted
the game really is the core story mode
takes place in a wide open environment
composed of a handful of different
biomes I tried the tutorial area turbo
Acres as well as a large arizona-like
area called big you and the world map
showed at least three more to explore
each of these is littered with garages
to act as fast travel points races stunt
jumps and other activities most of these
are integrated right into the open world
so you can simply pass through a gate to
start a quick event say a challenge to
jump over several barns the open worlds
in Lego 2K Drive reminded me of the best
moments of Burnout Paradise or Forza
Horizon roaming the landscape and
looking for fun activities jumping into
one and then driving around to look for
the next the vehicles themselves have a
solid weight to them gripping the road
in a way that even some more traditional
racing games don't quite nail your
vehicles aren't limited to traditional
cars either the Landscapes often have
large water structures as well as
off-road grounds since your vehicle is
made of Lego it instantly reconstitutes
itself into matching the type of terrain
that it's on you can freely roam around
the streets in a hot God and the moment
you go off-road a satisfying click lack
of Lego bricks rebuilds around you to
make an ATV score a big jump off of a
cliff into a nearby River and click
clack you're driving a boat
feels frictionless like the whole world
is your playground and nowhere is off
limits as you explore and unlock new
vehicles each with their own stats you
can make separate loadouts with
different combination of roadsters
off-road vehicles and boats that will
swap in automatically as you play that
feeling of freedom is further
accentuated by the integration of Lego
bricks into gameplay whereas most racing
games punish you for running into
pedestrians or other cars Lego 2K Drive
encourages it smashing through a Lego
structure or NPC vehicle breaks them
into a thousand clinking pieces and
helps charge your Boost meter like the
Quick Change vehicle mechanic the game
cleverly takes an element that's usually
a momentum killer in most arcade Racers
and turns it into a strength based on
The Familiar trappings of Lego toys the
open world activities and story missions
are similarly varied one moment you
might be jumping from road to off-road
to water for a time trial and in another
whether you may be fending off evil
robots with EMP blast occasionally you
can even find an optional mission that
will have permanent effects on the open
world the story is humorous and
self-aware with sharp writing that would
be right at home in the Lego movie
franchise but 2K Drive doesn't let a
tumor get in the way of gameplay as most
of the funniest lines were delivered
while I was out driving and exploring
seen anyone that good at drifting since
I looked in the mirror this morning
[Music]
this could turn obnoxious if jokes end
up eating themselves but in the time I
played I didn't hear that happen the
core cast of characters the villain your
Mentor the announcers are rounded out by
various Rivals who have their own unique
gimmick and personality one rival a
scientist driving a space rover-like
vehicle had a stream mission in which
she came face to face with herself from
the Future Lego provides a wide enough
range of genres to provide a rich canvas
for the writing to explore the Racing
controls are intuitive and easy to get a
feel for making it very satisfying to
just wander around in addition to a
drift button there's a dedicated button
for quick turns and another for jumps
many arcade Racers combine these all
into one function but I found having
them separated gave more fine control
and finesse the game's creative director
Brian Silva told us at Gamespot quote
our approach was to make the game feel
like you imagine it feeling when you're
playing with Legos as a kid it feels
real to you you're not playing with toys
it may have been enough to Simply make a
Fun open World Racing game in the mold
of burnout but Lego 2K Drive takes it a
step further the traditional races
available both in the open world and
through a separate Grand Prix menu are
reminiscent of the Mario Kart franchise
the colorful Lego presentation makes
this a natural fit and while racing
you'll pick up a variety of weapons via
randomized boxes just like in Mario Kart
it only took a short time to learn the
weapon icons which are easy to read and
understand some of these weapons include
the Homing rockets that fire
heat-seeking projectiles or the ghosts
that makes you invulnerable but also
prevents you from picking up boosts for
the most part these were relatively
standard fare which helped with the easy
readability but some were a little more
unusual Square wheels for example makes
for a bumpy ride when you're inflicted
with the status all the same mechanics
from the open world segments are on
display in the races as well from
smashing through the environment for
Boost meter to quick changing vehicle
Types on the Fly the drift complete with
a drift boost will make dedicated Mario
Kart fans immediately feel at home
foreign
this being a Lego game the concept
wouldn't feel quite right without a
building element the garages that serve
as fast travel points also offer a
robust construction tool letting you
build new vehicles across all three
categories or edit the ones you've
already unlocked I briefly tinkered
enough to put a pair of wings on a hot
rod which didn't make it airworthy but
it did look really neat the construction
tools are remarkably easy to use with a
Snap-On interface that imitates real
Lego building right down to the
satisfying click of putting a piece in
place I didn't have enough time to
experiment with how editing a design
might impact the vehicle's handling or
other stats but it's at least very easy
to make a car look the way you want the
library of brick types are substantial
encompassing just about every major one
I would have thought to look for as a
Lego fan and some that I didn't and just
like real Lego you can also follow the
instructions an instruction mode lets
you build a model step by step isolating
a handful of pieces at a time and
letting you click them into place
yourself this is the closest I've seen
to imitating a real Lego build in a
virtual space with the same relaxing
Cadence of putting a set together the
functionality was only present for the
preset models that were available at my
demo and I was told that sharing your
Custom Creations will be coming post
launch in fact it sounds as if developer
visual concepts has ambitious plans for
Lego 2K drive to last quite a while
according to Silva the studio is already
planning four major updates an
additional biome with its own mini story
and more details that are under wraps
for the time being describing Lego 2K
Drive is almost overwhelming there's so
much to do and see and so many smart
ways the systems fold into each other
for a seamless experience but in the
moment while playing it's anything but
overwhelming it's a breezy pick up and
play experience that uses its multitude
of systems and options to feel expansive
without getting in the way of the fun
Lego 2K Drive is coming May 19th